nur Prinzip punktuell ist nicht
besprechen
Pünktlichkeit soll an dieser Stelle kein
schlechtes Zeichen sein
wir haben uns an den Verhandlungstisch
gesetzt durchaus in dem Wissen was es zu
besprechen gibt
wir mussten uns nicht noch einmal
wiederholen immerhin fanden eine Reihe
von Gesprächen bereits statt
sowohl am 12 Januar fanden solche
Gespräche statt wie auch an anderen
Tagen da haben wir uns nicht wiederholt
wir haben viele Äußerungen bereits
gehört und auch die erste Reaktion der
USA haben wir vernommen auf das was in
dem besagten zwei Formaten besprochen
worden ist von unseren Stellvertretern
auch wir wurden um eine Reaktion gebeten
und wir wurden auch gewarnt welche
Reaktionen es geben würde
und im Grunde genommen haben wir
wirklich
lediglich nachfragen müssen das war
bereits im telefonformat möglich mit
Anthony blinken haben wir bereits
darüber gesprochen dass es eine
schriftliche Äußerung geben soll
bezüglich unserer beiden
Vertragsentwürfe die wiederum
beschriftlich erfolgt sind und all das
ist heute auch erfolgt
guten Tag eine Frage von NTV in den 70er
Jahren zu Zeiten des Helsinki Vertrages
haben die Verhandlungen drei Jahre
gedauert
haben würden Sie sagen es gibt eine
ähnliche Atmosphäre ein ähnliches Gefühl
wie damals oder kann es sein dass alle
Verträge in den Boden getrampelt werden
die vorher geschlossen worden sind was
würden Sie sagen
nun ja was unser Gefühl anbelangt
darüber kann man schwierig sprechen muss
ich gestehen es wurde mal etwas
versprochen dann wurde es nicht
eingehalten das kennen wir leider
bereits darauf habe ich bereits Bezug
genommen ich habe auch über die Worte
des amerikanischen Präsidenten
nachgedacht und mich darüber geäußert
das war 1975 nach dem Abschluss der
Helsinki Gespräche Jared ford war das
damals glaube ich und er hat sehr
feierlich verkündet dass die Verträge
unterzeichnet wurden und hat gesagt die
kommenden Generationen werden uns
beurteilen nicht nach den gegebenen
Versprechungen sondern nach den
erfüllten Versprechungen und dieses
Zitat klingt nach
und ich muss sagen unsere NATO
Gesprächspartner haben da sind dem nicht
so ganz gerecht geworden wenn ich das so
sagen darf es ging auch sehr viel um die
eine Freiheit der Wahl mit wem möchte
man sich verbünden darüber haben wir
auch gesprochen es gibt auch eine Reihe
von Verträgen Dokumenten auch im Rahmen
europäischer Gespräche es ging auch
darum gewisse Schritte unbedingt
vermeiden zu wollen um keinen Staat
einer möglichen Gefahr auszusetzen
wir haben mit Herrn blinken und seinem
Team darüber gesprochen und sie darum
gebeten zu erläutern wie sie diesen Teil
der Vereinbarungen auslegen für sich
denn leider wurde durch die OSZE kein
einziges Mal die Erfüllung auch nur
eines einzigen Punktes festgehalten
Anthony hat gesagt dass er durchaus
zufrieden ist mit dem Meinungsaustausch
der stattgefunden hat nächstes Jahr
bzw nächste Woche würde uns ein
Schriftstück vorgelegt werden so wurde
uns das gesagt
the with no friends from
information
dann hat man aber gesagt
dass es Neonazi und rechte Gruppen in
der Ukraine gibt aber wie hat denn das
russische Außenministerium reagiert auf
diese Einlassungen des amerikanischen
Außenministeriums und dann werden ja
jetzt Waffen geliefert aus dem feindigen
Königreich und USA wie hat das ihre
Gespräche beeinflusst ich muss sagen da
haben sie mir alles schon vorweggenommen
sie haben ja alles schon erläutert es
gibt tatsächlich Papiere diese zum
heutigen Treffen vorbereitet wir haben
da aber bestimmte Bevollmächtigte die
wir damit beauftragt worden sind diese
Personen sind dazu verpflichtet alle
diese Dokumente zu studieren und eine
Reaktion dazu gab es bereits schon ich
sehe da ehrlich gesagt keine
Notwendigkeit da weiter einen Kommentar
abzugeben ich könnte da durchblättern
und eigentlich egal welche Seite ich
aufschlage bin ich sicher
wird keine
da wird nichts umgesetzt es ist schlicht
und ergreifend eine Lüge die da drin
steht keine Verpflichtungen werden
umgesetzt zu der Frage bezüglich dessen
was heute besprochen worden ist so war
das natürlich die Ukraine Frage wir
haben versucht da bei Details zu klären
Positionen abzustecken wir haben
versucht darüber zu sprechen wie es
weitergehen könnte wie man einen
deeskalationsprozess vorantreiben könnte
jedoch möchte ich erneut betonen dass
wir die Gespräche abgeschlossen haben
mit dem dass wir nächste Woche eine
schriftliche
umfassende Antwort erhalten werden auf
jede einzelne unserer Fragen
unter anderem geht es natürlich darum
dass die Ukraine behauptet sie würde
keine Bedrohung für Russland darstellen
das war ich leider sehr stark von
unserer Position ab
denn
da sehe ich keine Bestätigung darin
niemand hat jemals der Ukraine gedroht
seitens der russischen Regierung das
möchte ich erneut bekräftigen
aber die Ukraine wiederum oder auch
andere Partner verkünden sehr wohl offen
und lautstark
ihre Position die sehr anti-russisch ist
es ging auch um dombasta gibt es große
Aufstände es geht dabei auch um
Terrorismus und es gab auch
Beleidigungen gegenüber russischen
Vertretern die
russischen Staatsbürger die auf
ukrainischem Territorium reden die leben
sie werden beschimpft und das sind
Szenarien die nun mal stattfinden und
ich weiß im Westen läuft auch eine
Maschinerie gegen Russland
doch was ich dazu lediglich sagen kann
ist wenn man in dombas zum Beispiel
irgendwelche militärischen Handlungen
motiviert
so muss ich sagen so sind alle jegliche
Handlungen auf dieser botage der
minskervereinbarungen ausgerichtet das
muss man leider festhalten denn wir
haben alle Möglichkeiten zur
Deeskalation
Raum gelassen doch ich muss sagen
inzwischen
wartet das ganze ein bisschen aus uns
wird immer wieder gesagt dass der
Truppenaufmarsch ein bisschen zu extrem
geraten ist wir bekommen Gegenwind aus
der EU und wir haben natürlich auch
heute mit meinem anderen amerikanischen
Amtskollegen darüber gesprochen wir
sprachen darüber dass wir den Dialog
etwas ruhiger konstruktiver gestalten
sollten und ich hoffe dass ihr Folge
dessen die Emotionen sich dahingehend
ein wenig legen
eine Frage von CNN haben sie
Fortschritte gemacht bei an der Punkte
die Russland angesprochen hat sie sagten
ja das sei von besonderer Bedeutung für
ihre Sicherheitsinteressen und gibt es
eine Enttäuschung ihrerseits und vor
allen Dingen wie sehen Sie denn die
Gefahr eines Krieges in Europa
angesichts dieses großen Truppen
Aufmaßes an der Grenze zur Ukraine und
dann noch eine Frage deshalb macht
Russland das jetzt gerade weshalb haben
Sie den Eindruck dass sie jetzt so
vorgehen müssen denn die Position der
NATO hat sich ja nicht verändert in den
letzten Jahren am Ende bestimmte Art
Fragen zu stellen
ich muss sagen wir müssen da vielleicht
die Arbeitsmethoden der CNN auch
besprechen denn es geht auch um die
okurate Darlegung von Fakten sie
behaupten wir würden planen in der
Ukraine einzumarschieren wir haben
mehrfach betont dass dies nicht der Fall
ist doch sie behaupten dass immer wieder
und dann fragen Sie jedoch warum jetzt
und ich frage wann dann es ist eine sehr
seltsame Frage ihrerseits muss ich sagen
was unsere Grundhaltung anbelangt
zur Konflikt Beilegung
und dazu dass die Osterweiterung der
NATO gestoppt werden muss so habe ich
meine Position immer wieder betont
mehrfach und ich habe heute ebenfalls
gesagt dass ich mich bei den USA
erkundigt habe wie sie da ihre
Verantwortung sehen im Rahmen der OSZE
zum Beispiel gab es Maßnahmen die
bereits auf europäischer Ebene
bekräftigt wurden es geht um die
Gewährleistung der Sicherheit aller
beteiligten Ländern ich habe die USA
gefragt heute wie wird die USA ihre
Verpflichtungen erfüllen und nächstes
Wochenende oder nächste Woche hoffe ich
dass wir da schriftliche Papiere
vorliegen haben werden die sich auf
diese Fragen beziehen
was um die Osterweiterung was die
Osterweiterung anbelangt
kann ich folgendes sagen das ist ein
Plan der ganz klar gegen die Russische
Föderation ausgerichtet war die aus der
Erweiterung ist festgehaltene
schriftlicher Form das wissen sie auch
und als zum Beispiel Osteuropa Polen zum
Beispiel die baltischen Staaten sich der
NATO angenähert haben so haben wir den
Westen damals gewarnt dass das ein
Fehler sein wird
denn es macht auch die nato-verwundbar
es wird Extremisten anheizen zu
bestimmten Handlungen
dieser starken wurde zugelassen
und uns wurde zugesichert warten sie
doch erst einmal ab sie werden ein sehr
friedliche Nachbarn haben es werden
Verbündete sein die in Nähe sind doch
leider Gottes ist alles anders gekommen
denn jetzt hat Polen auch auf einmal da
sagen hier und da und wir sind dazu
gezwungen eine sackgassenpolitik zu
betreiben
daher rufe ich die CNN dazu auf ihre
Fakten etwas akkurater zu prüfen
Nikolai Warnow ist vestia
ich habe folgende Frage angeblich hat
Anthony blinken heute erneut mit
Maßnahmen gedroht sollte es zu einer
erneuten russischen Aggression kommen
was wären die weiteren Schritte sollte
es dazu kommen
ich habe das bereits ebenfalls
kommentiert
erneut haben unsere amerikanischen
Partner
versucht die Ukraine heute in den
Mittelpunkt der Gespräche zu stellen
sie stehen weiterhin zu ihren
Ängsten zu ihren Befürchtungen so haben
sie es formuliert uns wurde zugesagt das
möchte ich und muss es erneut betonen
wir brauchen eine schriftliche zus und
wir hoffen dass wir nächste Woche damit
rechnen können und wir hoffen auch dass
sich die ukrainische Seite dahin gehen
äußern wird ich habe keinen einzigen
kein einziges Argument gehört
dass eine andere Auslegung der Situation
an der Grenze beschreibt außer
Befürchtungen Befürchtungen und wiederum
Befürchtungen
aber es
haperte ein bisschen an realen Fakten
muss sich in ehrlich sagen es geht wohl
um hunderte westliche Militärexperten
die nun auch in die Ukraine reisen
werden es geht um Manöver es geht um
Trainingseinheiten Militär Trainings und
das ist doch eine sehr unerwartete
Wendung der Ambitionen der EU auch wie
ich feststellen muss denn die EU sieht
das anscheinend als notwendig an an ihre
präsen zu erinnern
wir gehen nach wie vor davon aus dass
die Ukraine Frage eine sehr drängende
Frage ist jedoch sollte nicht
das gesamte Problem der europäischen
Sicherheitspolitik auf die Ukraine
reduziert werden und Herr blinken hat
auch erneut die Worte des amerikanischen
Präsidenten beiden bekräftigt und ich
habe erneut dazu aufgerufen
seinen Einfluss auf das kira-regime dazu
zu verwenden um diese sabotage-maßnahmen
eine sehr wichtigen Dokuments das wir
fordern
da einzugreifen
folgende Frage
ging es auch um die militärische
Infrastruktur Russlands
in Bezug auf Venezuela
finden da Gespräche statt mit den
Vertretern dieses Landes nein dieses
Thema haben wir heute natürlich nicht
besprochen
Redaktion TAS folgende Frage guten Tag
sie haben bekräftigt dass heute nicht
das letzte Gespräch war das zwischen
ihnen beiden stattgefunden hat was
planen Sie zu tun nachdem sie die
schriftlichen Antworten vorliegen haben
wird dass ein Gipfeltreffen geben oder
nicht und noch eine Frage
wie würden Sie die militärische
Unterstützung für die Ukraine
kommentieren seitens des Westens denn es
wurde immerhin auch immer wieder
beteuert dass man
auch mit Tschechien besprechen möchte
wie man da weiterhin die Position
stärken möchte wie bitte ich bin etwas
verwundert ich glaube sie haben sich ein
bisschen undeutlich ausgedrückt etwas
verwirrend war das denn ich habe bereits
gesagt dass wir auf eine offizielle
Antwort warten nächste Woche diese
Antwort soll bitte schriftlich erfolgen
danach planen wir ein erneutes Treffen
auf der gleichen Ebene wie heute wir
möchten da nicht Vorpreschen wir warten
ab denn natürlich wird auch Rücksprache
gehalten mit dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten und ich denke dass alle
weiteren Treffen sehr detailliert
vorbereitet werden müssen ausgearbeitet
werden müssen und dann werden wir
entsprechende Maßnahmen vorbereiten und
das komplette Potenzial ausschöpfen was
uns vorlegt was die tschechische
Regierung an oder andere Äußerungen
so muss ich sagen werden wir erst
reagieren wenn diesen Worten auch Taten
folgen wenn wir irgendwelche konkreten
Zeichen sehen der Unterstützung oder
andersherum alles andere kann ich nicht
kommentieren ich kann nicht kommentieren
was unsere NATO Nachbarn machen was
unsere Nachbarn aus den europäischen
Staaten machen denn wir haben das
öfteren Worte warnende Worte finden
müssen zu den
Tätigkeiten des keva-regimes
es geht darum dass Dinge verdeckt werden
verfälscht werden und das die westlichen
Partner durchaus auch ausgenutzt werden
für diese Zwecke und wenn diese Hysterie
erstmal
vielleicht etwas ruhiger stattfindet
sich ein wenig beiligte so kann man dann
in Ruhe sprechen
ich denke viele Menschen in der Welt
machen sich Sorgen auch angesichts der
Gespräche der stellvertretenden
Außenministers jabkoffer und Frau
Schirme in der letzten Woche sie
sprachen von einer schriftlichen Antwort
seitens der USA in der kommenden Woche
könnten sie das ein bisschen näher
ausführen ist das ein Schritt in die
richtige Richtung ist das ein
Zugeständnis der USA ihre Auffassung
nach und wie lange wird Russland warten
auf eine zufriedenstellend
ja wissen sie es gibt gewisse versuche
alles erneut und erneut durchzukauen und
ich finde das ist heute nicht der Platz
ich habe bereits sehr offen und
detailliert dargelegt worüber wir
gesprochen haben es war ein
konstruktives Gespräch ich kann nicht
sagen ob wir auf dem richtigen Weg sind
auf dem falschen Weg sind ich muss sagen
das werden wir erst selbst verstehen
sobald
die schriftliche Antwort seitens der USA
vorliegt guten Tag mein Name ist
Konstantin von dem Fernsehsender Stern
[Musik]
was
halten Sie davon dass das Weiße Haus
seine Unterstützung auch für einige
Regionen der Ostukraine zugesagt hat es
geht auch um das angekündigte Referendum
haben sie da bereits eine Meinung zu nun
ich möchte natürlich von jeglicher
Spekulation absehen was das Referendum
anbelangt dass sie erwähnt haben es war
tatsächlich ein Wendepunkt damals in der
Geschichte der ukraine-krise wenn ich
das so nennen kann das war nach dem
regierungssturz
und seitdem fragen wir eigentlich stets
was genau ist da passiert als die
Regierung gestürzt wurde was genau hat
zu dieser Ukraine Tragödie geführt und
dann kam es zu Krim wird uns immer
wieder gesagt dann kam es zu dombas und
wir sagen immer wieder Freunde was ist
denn mit den Friedensverhandlungen die
wir geführt haben den Friedensverträgen
die abgeschlossen wurden zwischen der
Opposition und dem Präsidenten damals es
gab um Garantien seitens Frankreichs
Deutschlands und Polens und dann hat die
Opposition das zerrissen das
beschlossene Dokument und auf einmal
wurden da sehr extremistische Stimmen
laut
und wie gesagt dann ging es wieder um
die Krim dann ging es um Truppen auf
Meerschwein der Krim und so weiter und
so fort und danach kam es erst zu diesem
Aufmarsch
seitens der Ukraine was dombas anbelangt
so gab es ein Referendum in donezkut in
lugans
und dieses Referendum wurde im Rahmen
des Normandie Prozesses besprochen es
ging darum auch in den
minskervereinbarungen und wir wurden von
Frankreich und Deutschland
immer wieder bombardiert mit Fragen und
mit bitten dass wir da unsere
Unterschrift drunter setzen unter diese
Vereinbarungen
um das
vierer-nummern die Format es ging um die
Unabhängigkeit aber es ging auch darum
dass die minskerverträge stets
ausgeführt werden müssen alle Maßnahmen
die darin beschlossen wurden mussten
erst ausgeführt werden damit eine
Reaktion erfolgt es ging um
Dezentralisierung zum Beispiel
es ging um amnestin es ging um
Wahlen
es ging um alle diese Themen
und das muss natürlich immer ein enger
Abstimmung mit Donut und mit Lugansk
erfolgen und da wird es verwirrend denn
das ist der Status den wir nun mal haben
den vieles wurde nicht umgesetzt die
Minsker Vereinbarungen liegen auf Eis
da geht es auch um die Rolle
Deutschlands und die Rolle Frankreichs
und wir stellen immer wieder die Frage
wie wir das bewerkstelligen können dass
das kever-regime weiterhin freie Hand
hat das zu machen was es will und das
was es gemacht hat
wir möchten einfach nur dass die
Vereinbarungen umgesetzt werden
sprach von einer neuen europäischen
sicherheitsordnung auch gegenüber
Russland was halten Sie denn von dieser
neuen Provokation
ich habe die Frage nicht ganz verstanden
was hat der Präsident gesagt man muss
eine neue Ordnung gegen Russland
schaffen
ja in dieser Woche hat Präsident macron
eine neue sicherheitsordnung für Europa
gefordert
Richtung Europa sollte stark gegenüber
Russland sein ist das für sie eine
Provokation ich muss sagen ich habe
Präsident macron und das nicht zu sagen
hören dass irgendein Format geschaffen
wird gegen Russland es ging immer um
andere Dinge die ich vernommen habe von
französischer Seite es ging stets darum
eine wichtigere Rolle einzunehmen das
ging darum um strategische Autonomie
im Moment werden auch Verträge
ausgearbeitet eines der Dokumente eines
ganzen Bündels an Dokumenten und
natürlich beobachten wir auch diesen
Prozess stetig es geht aber auch um
russophobe Ansätze
und wir haben unsere Partner aus der
NATO und aus der EU stets dazu
ausgerufen sich zu beruhigen dass es
leider bisher nicht erfolgt eine
strategische Autonomie der EU wird
seitens der französischen Führung immer
wieder
beschrien doch ich glaube es ist
schlicht oder greifen denn
Missverständnis
was will Russland am meisten ein und
eine unstabile
abhängige Ukraine oder eine neue
Einflusssphäre
wissen Sie darüber haben wir heute auch
gesprochen über den Einfluss der Länder
und natürlich ist es so dass eine
instabile Ukraine ein wichtiger Faktor
ist für unser gemeinsames politisches
Dasein
doch dieser Instabilität
und ich bin sicher das verstehen sie als
Journalist sie verstehen mit Sicherheit
auch woher diese Dinge kommen
es geht auch um führerscheincode dass er
zurückgekommen ist nach Kiel von all
diese Sachen die dann daraufhin gefolgt
sind
das muss ich nicht weiter kommentieren
doch was die Einflusssphären anbelangt
so muss ich sagen habe ich entweder die
blinken heute gefragt wie er das
begründen kann was passiert ist nachdem
der kasachische Präsident
sich gestützt hat auf die Satzung der
OSZE er sprach von einer terroristischen
Bedrohung von außerhalb und da hat sich
öffentlich auch dazu
geäußert und hat verlangt das erklärt
wird warum das getan wurde es wurde aber
nun mal nicht erklärt und ich muss sagen
dass das leider das Wesen der westlichen
Welt widerspiegelt man hat irgendwie
anscheinend die Einstellung dass man
dann doch alles darf
schauen Sie sich zum Beispiel die
Handlungen der EU an von Reka meierhini
zum Beispiel die Vorgängerin von Herrn
Josef Barrel
hat noch im Jahre 2018 sich dazu
geäußert
es ging dabei um das Treffen der
Ständigen Vertreter der Länder bei dem
Balkan Gesprächen und sie hat sehr offen
bekundet und folgendes gesagt
wenn die EU in dieser Region präsent ist
so haben andere Parteien dort nichts zu
suchen und das ist nur ein Beispiel von
leider sehr vielen um diese Beispiele
spiegeln die Einstellung der EU wieder
und das spiegelt auch die Situation und
den gesamten Kontext im Osten
Europas wieder und man kann
da leider nicht in die Äußerungen der
NATO und der EU alle Wahrheiten und
Unwahrheiten stecken und miteinander
verbinden und leider Gottes schließen
viele Äußerungen auch eine enge
Beziehung zu Russland oder auch zu China
leider aus und diese Einflusssphären von
der sie sprachen
sie kommt ja nicht von ungefähr es gab
einen Kontext und natürlich möchte
niemand gewisse Einflusssphären
verlieren und einbüßen und nun gab es
mehrere Szenarien wie man diese
beibehalten kann und sein Einfluss
sichern kann und das haben wir alles
gesehen wir haben gesehen wie diese
Einflusssphären eingenommen wurden wie
das weiterhin praktiziert wird wie neue
Territorien mit einbezogen werden sollen
in bestehende Einflusssphären ich habe
sehr offen heute gesprochen mit Herrn
blinken es ist sehr bedauerlich dass
erwachsene Menschen ein solches Spiel
spielen
scheint wie ein Wettbewerb
wer cooler ist
wer mehr von was auch immer hat aber
wenn man erwachsen und geschallt an
diese Frage herangeht wie man die
moderne Weltordnung sichern kann und
gestalten kann
so geht es natürlich auch um den
Klimawandel es geht um andere globale
Bedrohungen wie Drogenhandel wie
Terrorismus das Gesundheitswesen es gibt
so viele akute Fragen akute Bedrohungen
die mit der Pandemie einhergehen und das
ist bei Weitem nicht die letzte Pandemie
der wir begegnen werden müssen das sind
die Fragen die man lösen sollte das ist
das
worum wir uns dringend kümmern müssen
und alles was wir zum Beispiel
Seitensprung des Präsidenten selensky
vernehmen das ist einfach nicht richtig
das ist nicht der richtige Kurs im
Moment sehen wir ganz eindeutig dass die
NATO die Ukraine als ihren
Einflussbereich betrachtet
ich höre die Frage leider nicht
hellabroff wird das Außenministerium die
schriftliche Antwort der USA
veröffentlichen
ist eine Frage die sie natürlich an
unserer amerikanischen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen richten sollten heute haben wir
diese Frage nicht tangiert denn es ist
natürlich ihr intellektuelles Eigentum
das in unsere Hände gegeben wird
deswegen finde ich sollten Sie da die
Gegenseite Fragen ich fände es richtig
wenn Sie mich fragen ich finde das
sollte schon öffentlich auch präsentiert
werden und ich hoffe dass die USA dann
nichts dagegen hat vielen Dank